what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
reaction video as you guys know i
started my channel with reactions and i
haven't done a one-on-one reaction with
you guys in a minute so before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell like
the video alright guys you already know
the deal if you've watched two or more
of my videos and you do not subscribe we
have beef
beef people the audacity of some of you
okay i know some of you have been
watching me for months i see my
analytics
and you don't subscribe a subscribe is
free dang it okay
so
today we're going to be talking about
this girl
i've never heard of her in my life but
her name is t
noir
um and today i'm gonna be reacting to
her video surviving alpha mentality
before
oh wait i already told you guys to
subscribe
apparently is not a fan of the red pill
so let's see what she has to say
women want to be contained well the
feminine women not the masculine
[ __ ] not these feminists but the
feminine women want a man that's keeping
their mother [ __ ] in check fifty year
old man is not the same you're thirty
year old woman i agree i know some of
you guys don't might not like hearing
that but
typically as women age they lose their
value the problem is today far too many
of you women think you're [ __ ]
special you're not special you're just a
woman
hi everyone welcome to this video my
name is t if you're new here and i don't
have my notes fully memorized
just thought i'd confess early so
obviously i'm away from my typical
recording enviro
honestly i've just been running on
straight vibes for like the past couple
of weeks which is good because it gave
me the bravery to like actually sit down
and do this video
but clearly not the discipline to commit
it to memory no but we're here now it's
all good onward we move oh yeah and i
really do hope everyone's day is going
well so uh wow
the day has finally come let me be clear
the he-man woman hater crowd has always
been a [ __ ] problem but in recent
years we've seen a spike in a similar
online niche that has been dubbed the
manosphere
now within the manosphere are a number
of groups that range from in cell
uprisings to masculinity seminars with a
common ground in sexist ideation
ideology is probably the better word
wait it's sexist
what am i doing
and i'm offended she didn't include me
a fat i just like to be included if
you're going to include the incels as a
group
what about what about the women red
pillars
me and ally
and dorsa there's like three of us the
audacity okay and feminist repulsion so
obviously this is perfect for me um this
is a safe space for me clearly and if
you want a full breakdown fd signifier
recently released a video diving deep
deep into the pits of the manosphere and
feek never disappoints when it comes to
a deep dive so check that out and you
just might see him pop up in the video
you just might see a couple people pop
up ah we'll see but today instead of
talking about the entire sphere i'm
jumping right into the line of fire and
tackling what some may call the worst of
the worst
alpha male podcast
now i understand this whole digital
alpha male mentality epidemic to be a
tool of persuasion which pretty much
promotes that the natural order of
humanity is for men to engage in morally
and ethically deficient behavior
specifically at the cost of women's
pride and respect now that's the key
that's the only way it hits furthermore
okay i need examples ma'am
i need examples if you're gonna if
you're gonna make a blanket statement a
statement like that i need examples but
maybe she's gonna get to it i don't know
more and this is the real kicker we
should like it
we should like it women should enjoy and
support this natural order we should see
it as less of a hindrance to us and more
of a humble sacrifice
for humanity
uh-huh
okay
so
when i first started writing this video
my initial response was
that [ __ ] ain't never gonna happen it is
like give it up because me and millions
of you know what let me just speak for
myself i'd rather cornrow grass and
because these alpha male ideals seem so
incredibly unfathomable you know what's
funny she keeps saying alpha males
none of the guys in the manosphere call
themselves alphas none of them
so i'm like did you even watch their
content
they'll describe alphas
and
describe the dynamic but none of them
call themselves alphas but i'll just
i'll keep going
i was like it's kind of silly to allow
myself to get super upset in the video
making process but then i take a look at
the world around me i take a look at
these constant missions to strip women
of their bodily autonomy
these constant debates about women's
respect and this is the other funny
thing is that
the manosphere isn't really that
pro-life
to be honest
but okay i'll keep going i'll keep going
i'll let her speak and women's purpose
that are happening on a political
level a congress floor level a supreme
court level
as if we really living in gilead and
that's when i said you know what
[ __ ] it i give myself permission to be
upset and i hope you watching this can
extend yourself that same grace because
these men might not be living if you're
that upset over internet [ __ ] i feel
like you need to get a life outside of
the internet
i'm sorry nothing
nothing should make you
that upset if it's a youtube video
go outside enjoy the sunshine you know
what i mean okay
not me i live in london but
they look sunny where she is okay in the
state of powerless delusion that i've
tried to comfort myself into believing
they are because where there's smoke
there's fire right
so there is still in the very least a
market for these ideologies across
genders and at its most extreme a world
that sustains and reinforces them and we
gotta talk today's video
what i have lined up for you for us
i'm sitting on a budget piece of
information
just you wait completing research for
this video was a pain in several
different parts of my body i had to
watch a lot of videos and listen to a
lot clearly not enough because yeah
you've already said two two things that
are not correct but okay a podcast a
majority of that happened on my phone
and while i'm not proud about what was
coming from within my phone it was pure
style and uniqueness on the outside
because this portion of today's video is
sponsored by tech accessories brand case
defy from case to phi i got four phone
cases two pre-made prints that i thought
were super cute okay i am skipping the
ad i won't do that to you guys okay
of today's video chapter one
sexual economics and the modern woman
you know i had a home girl finished her
p was finishing up her phd extremely
successful beautiful and then like spent
three years trying to find a husband
luckily for her she found one but like
that was her only goal in life
and
to me it was like
why you know is it that serious yeah now
it's easy for me to say because i was
married and you know i started my family
and all that so maybe i would feel
differently
but it was something to her that she
wasn't complete
until she had that because we can't just
undo our biology
right and that's what feminists they
always do is they try to act like our
biology isn't there but there's
biological reasons that we feel the way
we feel
and in order to survive historically we
had to reproduce
and that is why single childless women
over the age of 45 between
i want to say the income category is
over 50k per year
are the least happy
so
you can say i don't understand but
you're also not a woman so okay
and so as that desperation increases
a god like kevin samuels becomes more
and more appealing i remember this one
he was alluding to women have to have
children in order for their life to mean
something
you know and it's like that i think
that's a dangerous thing to really say
in a room full of women them saying all
this inflammatory things in a room full
of women who aren't saying anything
aren't challenging them sort of nodding
their heads what are you talking about
it's like they haven't watched any
manosphere content
fresh and fake it challenged all the
time that's someone in the manosphere
right
all the time
donovan sharp he gets challenged all the
time people get challenged in the
manosphere probably more than any other
sector of youtube half of the manosphere
is just arguing to someone who's doing
that a lot of them will feel oh he must
be right because these women aren't
saying anything i think at some point if
you really put them on the couch and
have them
deconstruct everything that they've ever
thought i really believe that at the
root of it it's the fear of being lonely
black women we know they're more than
the most educated population in the
country
but the
the byproduct of that is
black women have realistic
visions of that neil they're not the
most educated they're the most enrolled
liberal
success letter
where i can be
plus here's the other thing that women
do and i wouldn't even
i think he said black women but this is
women across the board we equate
our education
to our success as a person and in life
and the thing is
some of the dumbest people i ever met in
my life are the most educated i swear to
god
and my dad
smartest man i've ever met in my life
one percenter
and he was self-self-made self-built he
came from nothing built himself into
something he didn't have a college
degree
we make less money
by and large as women
and we're more educated so does it
really matter
okay sorry i'll continue
okay i got my degree i got access i'm a
hard worker i'm talented so i can get
all the things that they say that i
cannot get
and
on at some point
you gotta check off men
right or you don't have the whole
package yep and so
maybe the key is
like
divesting
no no pun intended the desire to want
all those things
which how do you tell that to black
women how do i tell that to black how do
you how do you undo our biology you
don't
you don't undo our biology because you
can't
and telling women not to prioritize
family what are you gonna do
when you're 65
70 and by your damn self
we have to think about the second half
of our lives being single is all fun and
games when you're young and pretty
and as much as people want to say that
the wall doesn't exist for women
um sure some girls can look good to
their 40s but 50s 60s
who looks that good in their 50s and 60s
they might be doing decent
but they're not like killing the game
anyways the most beautiful women in the
world they're never 55 year old women
no they're like 25 22. anyways
as a black man because then i start
sounding like kevin samuels and like how
do i say that to black women as a black
queer woman oh my god so you're not even
straight
you have a depicted on male female
dating okay okay sorry and you can't
because i know they'll come for you the
same come from you once
let's call a spade a spade there are
many women out there who have a
deep-seated fear that they will end
their lives without first becoming a
wife or a mother yes
biology yup and these podcasters
awareness of this fear couldn't come at
more of an advantage to them because not
only did they not have to do the leg
work of making that fear a reality but i
think they're also aware that the work
it would take for women to not only
combat that fear internally but to
defend themselves against the shame and
humiliation that would be hurled at them
externally while also accepting that
after all is said and done they still
might not get chose like they really
might actually die alone a lot of them
will because 50 of women over over 30
are single and childless
i don't she just had a lot of big words
that basically just meant
i hate it when people use big words for
no reason to try to sound smarter than
they are i don't know her personally
okay
i'm not
but i hate it when people
pet peeve okay anyways
my point is this
yeah
dying alone is a fear of women it's a
fear of mine i don't want to die
alone it's okay
okay
it's too much work
these podcasters recognize that that is
too much work for most women and we know
that too we being women who have or are
in the process of letting that fear go
we know that [ __ ] can be difficult which
is why ken foster says a lot of y'all be
feminists in the streets pick me in the
sheets but what this allows though is
for these podcasters to bring women onto
their shows
explain their clearly imbalanced ideals
to them some of which may tamper with a
couple human rights and paint the
narrative that all they're trying to do
is just not make that fear a reality
they're just looking out for us
you know trying to do what's in our best
interest tough love essentially
according to the alpha male universe
a woman is a being whose ultimate
aspiration is cisgender heterosexual
marriage and procreative motherhood and
because that aspiration is like
hardwired into us apparently that's
where all women can trace their true
happiness and sense of self-importance
okay so this
this is what irritates me
no it is not all women
it is not all women
but if we as podcasters
are are talking about exceptions and not
the rule constantly
we can't have a conversation
and so what a lot of people try to do is
they try to say gotcha there's
exceptions to this okay yes there are
exceptions but it is not the rule
and if you ask most girls at the age of
18
if they want to be a mother and get
married someday the majority say yes
the traditional woman
the respectable woman has no problem
accepting that
but a modern woman
she tries to work her way around it now
keep in mind to them marriage and
motherhood is every woman's indisputable
desire so a modern woman still wants
those things too
eventually
but in the meantime she spends her early
adulthood which many of these men deem
as a woman's prime
to essentially study this what is what
is that
yes it is a woman's prime because
physically you look the best
okay they surveyed men between the ages
of 20 and 80 across the board
and said
when do you find a girl the most
attractive
21 22 23 24
and this is what irritates me about
feminists
is they use these little backhanded
compliment or not compliments backhanded
insults and try to shame men for having
standards they prefer younger women
it just is what it is and we could shame
them for it we could say it doesn't
exist
but it doesn't change reality
and so if you don't let women know what
reality is
then you're giving them bad information
okay i'm done sexual economy identify
men's vulnerabilities therein and
exploit them to her selfish advantage
according to roy f beaumeister and
kathleen devos authors of sexual
economics sex as a female resource for
social exchange in heterosexual
interactions a heterosexual community
can be analyzed as a marketplace in
which men seek to acquire sex from women
by offering other resources in exchange
societies will therefore define gender
roles as if women are sellers and men
are buyers of sex economic principles
suggest that the price of sex will
depend on supply and demand competition
among sellers variations in product
collusion among sellers and other
factors in the case of the modern woman
the factors she would use to her
advantage are youth
beauty
and her being desired by multiple men
aka dm's jumping and she would couple
that with men's disadvantages of a high
sex drive
less opportunities to have sex which of
course depends on the man's environment
and his desirability as well like let's
not play and women colluding with other
women to withhold sex for men for
whatever reason the resources that the
modern woman would then gain from said
exploitation are hoarded solely for
herself
her stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] feminist self
what i'm seeing a lot is the definition
of women to these alpha males
is
an incubator for a baby
um
someone to
take half of your estate
uh someone who is not loyal
and
looks at life
through the lens of rational choice
theory which is a term in political
science that we use to talk about people
who will do what they think
is in their best interest at every
expense this is a belief system this
isn't the case this is to say basically
that oh people do not have any altruism
people do not care about others or
anything people are not empathetic and
that's the alpha male
mindset and perspective they don't see
women as
people human beings that can care about
another person the men in these podcasts
are basically saying that women want to
use you for your money use men for their
money
um
they will get bored of men and they will
all the podcasts say it is not money
alone it's money
money game
frame and muscles are the four things
that they talk about
so they don't say it's definitely not
money alone because they talk about all
the time that you've just jeff used jeff
bezos as a man with a lot of money but
he's not alpha in the way that he acts
in his relationship
and women won't jump ship if they feel
like you are the best that they can do
when a woman leaves what is she trying
to do better
no no girl leaves thinking oh if i leave
this i'm going to be alone for the rest
of my life
like come on come on anyways it
is going to better their situation it
totally negates any other type of
faculty in women to care about anything
else but what will better their
circumstances in a capitalist mindset
and she repeats this process with
multiple men typically beta men because
as we know alpha men don't get played
which typically results in multiple
sexual partners which makes her more
likely to bear children out of wedlock
or if she's a black woman be branded a
baby mama
and we already talked about that [ __ ]
and with this lower market value that
the modern woman has brought on herself
she still has the nerve to think that
she still deserves to settle down with a
good man okay
no
it says there are consequences for women
if they make the choice to sleep around
men do not prefer women with a higher
body count
and they never said that alphas don't
get played wars have been started over
women throughout the course of history
but
when it comes to
but the body count debate if a woman
gets married as a virgin she has an 80
chance of being in a happy marriage
after 10 years if she sleeps with five
partners
or more that that rate drops to a 25
chance
it has consequences
and on top of that men have a biological
imperative
to want to ensure paternity historically
because they wanted to make sure that
the resources they were passing down
were theirs
so i'm sorry this isn't a fun truth
but it just is what it is and that's
what the red pill it is rooted in truth
okay i'm gonna continue
a good high value man who will respect
her that's the modern woman first off
that's not modern
that's right if you sit with a
sociological lens and listen to these
alpha male insult type dudes
they have a very astute grasp on the
nature of hierarchies within sex like
this the concept of the sexual economy
that's just legit yeah the problem is
okay i'm gonna read to you what a high
value man is so
let me see hold on so i put in my notes
app
for a different stream i was doing um
okay okay
so he said alpha male in cells but i i
think it's tough to be an incel
if you're a high value man because a
high value managed to make 10k per month
must have made it for three to five
years other men must accept you as high
value you have to have a network of high
value men's how you how are you going to
be an incel and a high value man
like i'm just confused because i thought
these people dissected
the red pill but they don't even clearly
understand this visibility linked in
love level utility useful to others and
the group
so the issue isn't
that women want to settle down with a
good man even after a whole phase okay
they're not saying you can't do it
they're saying that there are
consequences and to the men with the
most leverage and the most options
they ain't picking you why on earth
would you wife a hoe
if you have the option of everybody
there's a lot of guys that'll do it but
the problem is when a girl sleeps with
too many guys
she'll never settle
nothing is ever good enough for her okay
because their prescriptions of it
are all [ __ ] up but like
you know that's money muscles game and
frame that's their prescriptions
so
like that would help you sir you kind of
look like a little chunky
muscles okay muscles
game learning to talk to women
holding your frame being masculine
leadership
and making more money
okay is that is that a bad prescription
anyways
not new the cost of the cost of the
price of
of sex is different for women thus women
are get to be more choosy you know what
i'm saying and so that means yeah like
you
may not get access to
a to the partners that you desire
sorry really that's the sad thing about
all this manosphere stuff is that
they're responding to a real problem but
they're giving the worst solutions from
it i think money muscles game and frame
oh my god okay the actual modernism lies
to to women their advice is get in the
best damn shape of your life
stay as pure as you can
and go after the guys you want what the
[ __ ] the unconcealed nature of which the
sexual economy is engaged in so we are
in a time where there is less social
incentive to keep personal sexual
relations private in fact quite the
opposite there are obvious reward
systems in place for publicity of female
sexuality whether that's a hit record or
more followers on instagram so women are
more willing to and more supported when
they speak more openly about sex even if
the frequency of which they are speaking
about it doesn't necessarily match the
frequency of which they are having it
that is a result of ever shifting
popular cultural norms
not the random discovery of a modern
woman okay you made your bed lie in it
there's consequences with everything if
you choose to be open about your sex
life
cool
more power to you i don't care
but
if a man says hey i'm not comfortable
marrying a woman who's been super
open about her sex life for the past 10
years
he's allowed to do that and that's what
the men are saying
and if these men were to just
non-judgmentally ask women about that
instead of trying to recreate them in
their alpha male image they would tell
you even just exclusive to the
manosphere the alpha male content
creators it's them but also people who
sort of align with that without even
calling themselves alpha males a lot of
men value women in a certain way where
it's like they don't view women as human
beings with like you know their own
thoughts and opinions and feelings and
perspectives that they them like if you
really want to find some kind of
transactional value from women it's
perspective oh gosh this is such a
feminine
he talks like a girl okay
they only view women sexually
romantically
i think that's a terrible no they don't
guys okay i i deal with a lot of these
creators i've been to a manosphere
conference
they don't just view you for your
sexuality
the problem is we are talking about the
dating landscape and it starts with sex
it starts with a girl's fitness in her
face
does she have a banging body
it doesn't mean that's all the guy guys
care about
donovan talks so much about how his
girlfriend added value to his life fresh
and fit they talk about how the women
that they deal with add value to their
life outside of just sex
that's one of the biggest things that
they say in the manner sphere if you
want to keep a guy
add value to his life outside of just
sex horrible thing to it just irritates
me because i don't understand i thought
you watched so much of this content
but how do you not understand it oh my
gosh put across to an audience of people
especially to an audience of kids
because
some of these kids are watching they're
being taught to be sociopathic women
hating men
who value the wrong things value
materialism value sex value status over
being a decent person at the very least
but you hear that shaming language if
you know you know it's talking like a
lady shitty understanding aside alpha
male mentality references and blames the
modern woman and the sexual economics
theory for everything no
no that's not true i've asked so many
manosphere creators and they will tell
you that men are the problem too weak
men it is modern women and weak men
so
the problem is when women get called out
we get our panties in a bunch men don't
complain like this and then you have the
white knights
who come in
and are like oh no don't criticize women
you guys are man haters like shut up oh
my gosh we can get criticized to the men
get criticized all the time
okay
continue and that is incredibly
persuasive for their audience um give
them that one because they can follow
and reference a system of ideas that
have been researched and discorded
constantly being discorded in scholarly
spaces so it makes them sound smart
and two the sexual economics theory is
easily digestible
most people already view sex as
transactional anyway so whether they
recognize the words sexual economics
theory or not
they're probably still familiar with it
in practice
so that scholarly backing coupled with
the cultural familiarity are just a few
of the many reasons why these ideologies
can be pushed as
philosophy as if these podcasts are just
the tireless pursuits of knowledge and
truth
i haven't heard you
cite one stat
maybe it's coming though i don't know
what it really is [ __ ]
what it really is is the failure to
critically engage with a concept outside
of its reality or to even interrogate
the factors that made it a reality
they failed to do the thought labor and
to tell you the truth i feel like this
is why
oblivion is such a comfort zone for so
many people myself included because we
all love to assume that if we were alive
when insert humanity shifting historical
event here happened
that we would have been on the front
lines making the mission succeed
oh yes we would have been resisting we
would what are you talking about
this is the pro like feminists go on
these rants
like what
tell me what
data that they use that is incorrect
been abolishing we would have been
marching yet so many of us fail to
simply imagine a reality that is
different from what it currently is much
less be brave enough to take action and
change it
and maybe that has to do with the
egotistical ways in which we are taught
history in school
like for me
i was taught history as if the world now
now she's talking about history and
schools
ma'am stay on topic world we currently
live in is the best humanity has ever
been
so simply
by some standards it is if we're gonna
go down this route
there's less people in poverty than ever
before in the west
in the west
you damn are you damn sure are pretty
lucky to be alive in the west
they say that poor people that are that
are
what are they what do they call it
they're that are counted as um in the
census as under a certain income
or like needing welfare that sort of
thing they still have air conditioning
in
tvs it's a pretty good time to be poor
okay live at this point in time
girl we get to talk on camera for a
living
that is our job it is
[Music]
the best job on earth thank you guys
watching
yeah it's a pretty damn good time to be
alive
enough i am on the right side of history
because good history is happening right
now and you made a video
sorry like okay i'm literally alive i
feel like that's how i was started so
yeah i feel we are taught to create this
huge degree of separation between um
the horrors the documentary oh my god
she is not trying to imply that some
dudes on a podcast
is the same thing as the horrors of
history
of humanity and modern day
instead of again interrogating the
powers that created those horrors and
exposing the fact that those powers are
still in place they are just lying
dormant at best attacking others at
worst can you be specific
no she's not she won't
but we'll get there okay so yes failure
to engage with a concept beyond its
tangible reality the reality is
i feel you though i'd be milking i'd be
milking the watch time too sometimes
sexist undertones or not me despising
this [ __ ] or not the sexual economy is
participated in by a lot of people and
since human beings can survive without
sex but not without resources within
this economy
a gender imbalance will be borne out of
it the sexual economy functions because
female subjugation is woven into it on a
molecular level and obviously if you're
an alpha male enthusiast and your desire
is to feel needed
powerful and resourceful and women come
in and make that power useful
they make those resources useful
isn't that what creates the value in a
high value man
so i'm confused at the constant
criticism because
this works for you
in fact it works exactly how you
designed it the harsh truth is well yeah
every powerful man throughout history
one of the indicators that they're
successful is women
multiple women yeah okay i don't know
what your point is when you devote your
life they don't hate women
they don't i'm telling you
i've had some of the nicest like some of
these guys have been so nice to me
in the way that they helped me with my
channel when i literally they had no
incentive to do that
okay go ahead
to achieving these alpha ideals you are
literally signing up for constant
monetary and quantitative appraisals of
your worth as a human being
and that's why fulfillment struggles to
be found because with that mindset there
will always be an opportunity for your
humanity to be exploited what does that
even mean there will always be an
opportunity for your humanity to be
exploited
because you're judged based on your
results
now that's the opportunity for your
humanity to be exploited
that's what i mean like feminists say
they're always so well spoken but they
they're like well spoken saying nothing
nothing at all
i guess i swear to god i'm 20 minutes
into this video and you've literally
said nothing okay that's by women your
community or capitalism misha lima is a
tip-top creator with a plethora of
videos dedicated to this topic and just
like she said instead of just saying hey
this ain't working let's try something
different these alpha male enthusiasts
figure that the solution is to appraise
women's humanity in the same way it's
not appraising it's
it is looking at women by the results
they have in the world
what's her she's about to say it says on
the screen what's her body count what's
her dress size what's her shoe size how
many kids she got yeah
i'm sorry it's not it's not a fun
reality but the reality is if you have a
child less men will want to date you
if you are fatter less men will want to
date you
and what we're not going to do is go and
shame men for having standards
they are allowed to have standards and
date who they want and if by and large
men say we don't want to date a girl
with kids we because because and also
that's irresponsible why are you a
single mother
there are so many different forms of
birth control
i mean i understand sometimes you get
married you give it a go but did you
leave because women do leave seventy to
eighty percent of the time ninety
percent if you're college educated
what's her body count
yeah
men are allowed to want a girl that
hasn't slept around
anyways i
what's her body count what's her dress
size what's her shoe size how many kids
she got and they stick the worst of it
the worst of it onto black women we are
their easiest target because black women
out of all women
are the most deviant from this white
supremacist capitalist sexist ideal of
which they all continuously fail to
dominate the black gym i'm going to be
honest this this isn't a fun truth but
black women have the worst results when
it comes to getting married they are the
least married
that
and they don't go in on just black women
i've seen i've seen these men humble all
types of women
they don't care
they'll humble any of you
what kind of wars
are as old as black comedy black
comedians you know what i'm saying that
goes back to patrice o'neill that goes
back to
even like a red fox you know what i'm
saying i remember growing up and local
radio would always have at least one
you know gender war segment a week where
like black men the same basically
basically clubhouse damn am i right i
should have but women
women
say the most sexist [ __ ] all the time
men are trash men are the problem ugh
men
and
okay we have we have women empowerment
what if they had men empowerment
women would have a problem with that the
only time women advocate for men is when
it benefits them for example we say oh
we want men to be more emotionally
available for us
for us okay that's the point i'm gonna
make but like you know how clubhouse is
now right yeah like that was black talk
radio in the 90s like it was the same
exact a man will call up and say women
this this this and the woman will call
up and say a man that that that and
there would usually be a man and a woman
like dj and it would be the same
nonsense
so like
the he-man woman hater black dude is a
old trope that's just i think become
more lucrative
as the world has awakened to the
love of embarrassing black women again
the he-man woman it's not it's not the
love of embarrassing black women it's
the love of embarrassing delusional
women
we don't care we don't care what you
look like
we don't care if you're delusional well
we are all gonna tell you that you are
delusional
sorry i'm done crowd is nothing new
but reserving a special layer of
humiliation specifically for black women
is what takes this from silly ignorant
locker room talk to
manosphere
to profitable
wealth amassing fame building alpha male
podcast we can talk one of kevin
samuel's most viral clips was a white
woman
it was when he was on fresh infinity
called in
the manosphere knows what i'm talking
about you could google it days about the
expected female subordination within
these ideologies and really get the
people going but when the face of who
that is primarily being aimed at doesn't
pass the paperback test
when the name ends in an isha or an equa
when the archetype is opposite of what
people are okay this is just irritating
me so i'm just gonna show you
youtube
kevin
samuels
rest in
power
fresh
and
fit
okay
oh not this one sorry it was
oh it was this one no no no real quick
real quick real quick how's kevin says
samuels uh so we're just at him on
stream uh kevin welcome to the show man
uh wait no it wasn't this one
was it
married people there
um
okay um
you'll think differently probably by 37
no i see going back white girl
kevin samuels destroyed their hopes and
dreams of being moms
most of that panel was white this oh
this is what i was looking for
intimidated by this thing i'm not i'm
just challenging this girl this is one
of his most viral clips
okay let me
okay all right here we go i've been here
for quite a while this is everyone in
the manosphere okay
big players kevin samuels rolotomasi is
right there donovan sharp fresh and fit
a white girl and two latinas i think
can't really tell but who does he go on
in on let's see been here for a few
minutes hey guys how we doing we're good
kevin how are you
good
the ladies are in the middle her name is
sable
amanda but close enough amanda uh the
one the woman to her right your name is
adriana
adriana and the woman to your left
janina
janina okay one of the things i kept
hearing my name is kevin samuels by the
way nice to meet you
one of the things i kept hearing is the
notion of fairness fairness fairness
why is that so important to you amanda
i hate to admit it but i do like i'm
half a man i'm just a pretty girl and i
don't think that i should have to accept
less in life because i was born with
different equipment i think that's
[ __ ]
well if you're half a man that you
should understand this full concept that
men don't care about fair
i don't have to care about fair either
no no no men don't care about fair or
else we wouldn't conquer other people
here of european descent looks like you
from you looks like you're from
people are from the caucus mountains
european descent
huh i am very white yes that's fine and
some of them and there's a lot and
between
a lot of warring tribes germania the
franks
if we cared about fairness we would just
let everybody stay on their land
vikings wouldn't have raped and pillaged
england would have stayed on its island
scotland would have been all right
ireland would have been all right matter
of fact hong kong wouldn't have been a
british protectorate for how many years
oh until the last what 30 or 40.
men don't care about fair we conquer
it's winners and losers
straight up
right you're half a man i didn't know
that only men were part of conquering
okay i'm not gonna do this whole clip
but let me let me go later in the clip
because she gets mad i'm pretty sure
because you because you kind of start
talking over me so could you repeat it a
bunch of weak ass man doing what
yes
when somebody sits here and tells me i
need to accept an unfair situation
that if we applied it to anything else
in life other than men going back and
forth
can also do what she wants to do as well
and they have an understanding because
get when the the marital rate in this
country the divorce rate in this country
is over 51 percent but when you cross a
net income of 250 000 it drops to 20
okay anyway so you guys get the idea
this one went viral this is a repost and
it got more views
than your video and it's a repost
white girl okay sorry just irritates me
because i feel like she didn't watch any
of the content like
are trained to
instinctively extend empathy and
compassion to
these things get to happen without
consequence
chapter two
the disregarded devaluation of black
womanhood oh no
i saw a tweet that said i hate it when
[ __ ] try to act like
the freaking handmaid's tale is what's
going on today okay
the fact that they stay bringing up the
handmaid's tale to describe oppression
instead of the actual history of
state-sanctioned abuse towards black and
native women speaks volumes earlier in
this video i made a reference to gilead
which for those of you who don't know is
a fictitious nation in which the
handmaid's tale takes place the
handmaid's tale is a fictional show
about majority white women who have been
forced into sexual servitude the nation
of gilead has a main objective to
acquire and maintain power through fear
but it masquerades that objective as a
simple desire to encourage procreation
in an otherwise dying state of humanity
gilead interprets sections of the bible
quite literally citing scripture to
justify abuse
murder and other brutal forms of
punishment some of the most horrendous
rituals that take place in gilead
resemble the cruelties faced by black
women throughout history particularly
slavery for example just like the
handmaids enslaved black women endured
force procreation of children that once
born would become property of the estate
making them eligible to be ripped from
their mother's arms at any point another
example would be the sexual servitude
forced on enslaved black women
by masters or in this show commanders
and then the subsequent hatred are we
comparing this to red pill
what on earth is treatment by the
master's wife over rituals neither women
could control in ania woman in critique
of susan brownmiller's failure to
address the ongoing effects of black
women's sexual exploitation and slavery
bell hooks wrote she fails to see that
the significance of the rape of enslaved
black women was not simply that it
deliberately crushed their sexual
integrity for economic ends but that it
led to a devaluation of black womanhood
that permeated the psyches of all
americans and shaped the social status
of all black women once slavery ended
one has only to look at american
television 24 hours a day for an entire
week to learn the way in which black
women are perceived in american society
the predominant image is that of the
fallen woman the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
prostitute even though
there is real
nightmarish [ __ ] that real literal black
women have gone through and are still
feeling the effects of when we see these
governmental threats to women's bodily
autonomy and reproductive rights the
first thing people run to is oh this is
some handmaid's tale [ __ ] like this is
some fictional show [ __ ]
instead of realizing this is what the
handmaid's tale was inspired by
but it's just now threatening white
women too now i do want to give leeway
to the fact that handmaids is a
fictional show it is a story
yeah
what the story which means they have to
squeeze in a lot of theatrics into a
short amount of time to keep the viewer
engaged and recounting actual factual
nonfictional history does not award us
that luxury so i'll give you that
nevertheless the point is historically
if white women were not getting the
brunt of cruelty a blind eye was turned
and i believe that's exactly how these
podcasts even though i believe our hate
speech are radicalizing no no they're
talking about what men want and you are
trying to shame them for it
whenever a man has a standard i want a
girl that's in shape i want a girl with
no kids
women shame them especially feminists
and also are we going to talk about
if you're going to talk about how
plan
like because they always bring in
abortion when red pill i swear to god
it's not even really pro-life are we
going to talk about how planned
parenthood was a racist organization
started in the name of eugenics
and that 80 percent of planned
parenthoods are in minority
neighborhoods
and that they pay planned parenthood's
executives upwards of six figures to
market abortions in minority
neighborhoods
and that the plaque population would be
double today if it wasn't for planned
parenthood do we talk about any of those
stats
are they not important well we're
talking about bodily autonomy
okay anyways done large group of people
but we're not even
okay i'm done okay to hate and mistreat
and malign black women which puts us in
danger
are still protected these podcasts are
not just successful they are protected
why let's run it back
so far through alpha male podcast
reasoning we can deduce the following
one
the value of a woman's humanity is
defined by her sexuality no
no
no
a woman's value in the sexual
marketplace
not a w what the [ __ ] does a woman's
humanity like i just hate it
when people say words
that don't make any sense for no reason
just try to sound smart they know
okay okay
a woman's humanity no it's
in the sexual marketplace where do you
fall
not everyone can have the most options
okay period
positively if she uses it to please one
man and or produce children with him and
negatively if she explores or employs
her sexuality too much and because
but here's the thing that women don't
understand if you explore your sexuality
too much the most damage that it does is
to you because you can't be happy in a
relationship because again a virgin 80
chance of a successful marriage if you
sleep with more than five people 25
chance of a successful marriage is it
wrong for the men that say you know what
with odds like that i'll take the girls
that are closer to virgins no
it actually makes a lot of it makes a
lot of sense
okay and or for her soul benefit
and when you think about it
saying that a person's humanity is
determined by one particular thing that
in and of itself is gendered it's not
it's not their humanity like
it's not personal value and the red pill
differentiates this a lot they're
talking about people's value in the
sexual marketplace which is dictated by
supply and demand which women are the
most in demand
which men are the most in demand
that in and of itself are are we shamed
for not liking short men
are we shamed for not wanting to date
broke men
because high stakes like that are hardly
ever applied to men's humanity think
about it
i believe it was bridget kelly who once
explained that one of the ways
sexual inequality upholds itself is
allowing men the convenience to separate
their character from their actions
and that [ __ ]
it blew mine because no phil think about
it men can do some very heinous things
some very again
morally and ethically deficient things
and we can still turn around and
recognize that in other areas of his
life i.e his fatherhood his brotherhood
his competence as a worker or a
businessman we can recognize that in
those areas he is good okay let's take
oprah for example
oprah is not someone that men are just
lined up to date
but we can recognize that oprah is a bad
[ __ ]
she she ran a kick-ass talk show
but it's not
attacking her humanity
if you're saying
you know what men men aren't lined up to
date fat women i'm sorry
oprah i still think you're a bad [ __ ]
okay
and thus we overall deem him as a good
person whereas with women let her
sexuality for some reason be in question
let her sexual prowess be something that
upsets or causes discomfort in people
now all facets of her humanity are up
for questions here's here's the problem
is a lot of women
that take the only fans route and take
the sexual promiscuity route have a hard
time with self-control and want to take
the easy way out you have the option to
get a job and work hard
or you have the option to take off your
clothes on the internet
and we don't respect women that just
take off their clothes on the internet
or on the internet talking about sex all
the time that's the easy way out
but do you know what
you know what but oprah i respect the
hell out of oprah she didn't take her
clothes off on the internet she's a
respectable taco show host ellen
bad [ __ ] energy
not this like
okay okay i'm done
her motherhood
her sisterhood her competence as a
worker or a businesswoman jana pinkett
smith is a great example of this jada
pickett smith she just airs out all her
family's business on the freaking
internet
she's not a business woman
like i mean look it
i'm not even gonna complain because she
gives me content to react to okay
two
sexuality is women's only power which is
why something like the sexual economy
can even exist in the first place no no
no no
it's their primary agency
that's why when you see women at
political protests they take off their
clothes like what happened at the [ __ ]
march this isn't fun this isn't a fun
reality but the truth is
if we take off our clothes we get more
attention
because it harps on men's one and only
weakness
their horniness and three because female
sexuality is only powerful if weaponized
and sexuality is understood to be
fleeting with age women are ultimately
powerless
therefore their ordained position within
humanity is to be in submission of men
and then just multiply that pressure by
no in the sexual marketplace men prefer
submissive women
where's the demand the highest for what
look at this isn't fun i'm an athlete
man
i played basketball in volleyball i'm
not the most feminine woman in the world
i know girls much more feminine than me
that get more dates it just is what it
is
but like you hear this guys this is
these are the this is the type of woman
you got to avoid she likes girls so
that's good for all of you because
whenever
watch how women respond whenever men set
a standard if they set a standard and
they try to shame you for it insult you
for it
but leave them i'm telling you it's too
much of a headache
at least four if we're talking about
black women okay see
at this point you really gotta ask
yourself are these ideas just the
product of alpha male podcast reasoning
okay she's gonna go into like
christianity which
i wouldn't call myself like a bible
thumper
anyways my point is this
ma'am i don't even think you watched
hours of these podcasts like you said
this is what feminists do whenever men
set a standard
they shame them for it
anyways let me know your thoughts in the
comments don't forget to subscribe to
the channel bring that notification bell
and next time next time
i'd like to be included if the installs
get to be included i'd like to be
included okay thank you
i will talk to you guys next time don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell bye